- Hello, welcome to Khan Academy Ed Talks.
I am Caroline Hu Flexer,
the CEO and Co-Founder
of Khan Academy Kids,
which is a mobile app for
children two through eight
that's focused on literacy, math,
and social-emotional learning.
Today we are celebrating
National Reading Month,
and I'm excited to talk
with our special guest,
Kristi Yamaguchi, who is
a Olympic gold medalist,
author, and philanthropist.
If you have questions for Kristi,
please drop them into the chat.
And before we get started,
I wanna remind you
that Khan Academy is a
nonprofit organization.
We're able to do the work that we do
thanks to the generosity and donations
from folks like all of you.
So if you're able to give,
please go to KhanAcademy.org/donate
and you'll find a place where
you can make that donation.
And we are so grateful for
anything that you can give
to our mission.
I also wanted to recognize
the organizations
that have helped support our
work during the pandemic,
including AT&T, General
Motors, and Fastly.
Finally, if you want to
listen to this podcast again
or find previous broadcasts,
you can find them at Homeroom
with Sal, The Podcast
anywhere you get your podcasts.
So let's get started.
Today I'm thrilled to introduce you all
to Kristi Yamaguchi.
She is a wife, mother,
Olympic gold medalist,
children's book author,
and founder of the nonprofit Always Dream.
Kristi Yamaguchi's Always
Dream ensures that children
from low income families have access
to high-quality books.
Welcome, Kristi, it's
great to have you here.
- Thank you, Caroline,
it's great to join you.
Thanks for having me.
- Yeah, so the Winter
Olympics just finished.
This year is your 30th anniversary
since capturing the gold medal.
What is your most
cherished memory you have
regarding your Olympic experience?
We'd love to hear a bit more
about what the Olympics
were like back then.
- Yeah, so '92 was a while back, right?
But it was a incredible experience.
I think when you talk to any Olympian,
one of the most vivid
and fondest memories,
always marching in the Opening Ceremonies.
And I think just being a part
of an incredible group of
athletes, not just figure skaters,
but the skiers, the speed
skaters, the bobsledders,
biathlons, it's just an
incredible pool of talent
and it's so humbling.
And I think there's no prouder feeling
than putting on our Team USA uniforms
and marching in together
representing our country.
So that, I think, will always be
an incredible, special moment.
And you know, the Games
themselves are just
something that's a lifelong pursuit.
And it's so amazing just to be there
and an honor to represent.
But the competition gets a little intense,
as you can imagine.
But lots of fun, too.
I mean, I knew I was prepared
and I was ready for that moment.
And even though my nerves were creeping in
and giving me a little
bit of that scary feeling,
I kept telling myself, go out there,
do what you're trained to do,
and the preparation's going
to hopefully be something
I could rely on.
And it came through for me.
So I feel very fortunate every day.
- Yeah, it clearly did.
And I'm sure there were many life lessons
that you learned as a figure skater.
What were some of those that carried over
into your work now in
raising and teaching kids?
- I mean, that's such a great point.
And I think it's all about
having a dream, right,
and really going after those dreams,
and really encouraging kids
to use their imaginations
and to open up their minds
to what's possible out there
and then putting the time
in and working for it.
So all good stuff to kind of set goals
and encourage the kids to
really go after what they want
and put some work or effort into it,
and you never know what can happen.
- Absolutely, it's that
combination of the hard work
and the dreams that
clearly have taken you far.
So you've written three books
and you are also working with
early childhood literacy.
How did you get into
that from figure skating?
You started quite early
in your career as well.
- Yeah, so my organization Always Dream
was established in 1996.
And we are all about
embracing the hopes and dreams
of underserved children.
And the last 10 years, we've
really focused our efforts
on the early childhood literacy.
And I think really the
inspiration behind that
was being a mom, becoming a mom myself.
I had, I still have two daughters.
But at the time they were four and six,
so kind of at that learn-to-read age,
had an incredible, high interest in books
and just reading at home.
And I think my husband and I just saw
the incredible value that that had
and the pure benefits
that they received from it
as they were starting
to get ready for school.
And I think looking around in our country
and some of the statistics
of 60% of low income families
don't have age-appropriate
books in the home,
and close to 40% of our fourth
graders in the United States
are reading at or above grade level.
Those are numbers we
really want to change.
And I felt like that was something
I was really passionate about
and wanted to really turn our focus on.
- Absolutely, and now you're
working with school districts
and using technology to
help get those resources
into classrooms.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
- Yeah, so we have a program
called Always Reading.
And it's focused on
pre-kindergarten and
kindergarten age students.
And we're primarily in Title I schools,
so where resources are very much needed,
and provide one-to-one tablet with ebooks.
So wide range of selection
of titles and subjects
for the kids to pick from.
But we also pair that with
family engagement support.
And with that support, we
reach out to the families
three times a week with text messages.
And there's everything from
reading tips and strategies
to little gentle reminders,
like, "Hey, there's 10
new books in your library.
Why don't you pick one out and
read to your child tonight?"
And sometimes questions
to maybe ask your kids
as you're reading a
book with them together.
It's a program that we
really, really love to see
the change in behavior
of the families at home,
that they do set up a
literacy-rich environment
with their child and spend
that time engaging with them
and just understand the
importance and the impact
that that will have on their
child as they move forward
in their education.
- That's great.
And I love that you have
implemented these tips.
Do some of them come from
tips that you've acquired
as a mom as you were
teaching your kids to read?
- Definitely, I think
we do everything we can
to get them interested in books, right?
And sometimes it's not easy.
But I think keeping it fun
is always a great thing.
And even if it means just
picture walking a book
with your child, like looking
at a picture and asking them,
"Oh hey, there's 'Dream Big, Little Pig!'
What color is her dress?"
Or "What is she doing, is
she playing basketball?"
And then it prompts them
to kinda think and answer
and really get more involved
with what they're reading.
So keeping it fun was one thing for sure.
- Absolutely, kids are always playing
and learn the best through play.
So I love that playful
approach to learning.
Tell us about the children's
books that you've written.
- Yes, no, absolutely.
So there's three books.
One is called "Dream Big Little Pig!"
There it is.
Poppy the Pig, as you can see,
is interested in ice skating.
She tries a few different things
before she finds ice skating.
And once she finds ice skating,
she discovers she loves it.
And so this one's all about persistence
and not giving up and
going after your dreams
even though there's
challenges in front of you.
And then I also did a
follow-up from this called
"It's a Big World, Little Pig!"
And then "Cara's Kindness"
is about a caring cat
and she passes kindness forward
and only asks that her
friends do the same thing.
And you never know the
kindness can come full circle
back to you.
So each one has a little
bit of a positive message
that hopefully kids can take away
and maybe implement in their own lives.
- Yeah, and speaking of facing challenges,
we have a question from
Kushi from YouTube.
And she was asking, "How
do you keep going on
in spite of having low
scores or performance?"
I'm assuming in regards to reading.
Do you have some ideas for us?
- Maybe a parent or maybe
a teacher, sounds like?
You know, I mean, I think
it's like finding something
that will inspire that child
to really pick up books
as much as possible.
And I think it's important
to have options of choice
because when a child's
able to pick and choose,
they take a little bit of
ownership of what they're reading.
And I think that makes
it a little more fun.
It might prompt them to read
that book again and again,
which is always great.
Or even maybe inspire
them to find other books
in that same subject.
I think choice and letting
them pick is a big key
to getting them interested.
And maybe finding other fun ways
to get them reading.
Maybe even be outside and
if something interests them,
like they see a truck
go by and they're like,
"Wow, look at that big truck,"
and you can say, "Let's go
find some books about trucks
and learn more about them."
So little tricks like that, I think,
are great ways to get at a
child's interest in books.
Even if they don't realize
they're learning something, they are.
- Absolutely, especially for
the youngest kids, I think,
the songs and the rhymes
have so much phonemic awareness
skills that you can build
as you're singing those
songs and playing games, too,
with young kids.
So yeah, love that idea
of having choice, I think,
with books, hopefully
now, kids can find books
with subject matter interests
that they're interested in
and that can go on.
We have another question
from Sam Lewis from YouTube.
"How do you press on when
your faith is being tested
beyond all you can give?"
And I hear him, from all these
times during the pandemic,
especially with young children at home.
These are challenging times.
Do you have thoughts for Sam?
- Yes, that's a tough one.
And I think it's
something that we all face
at some point in our lives.
And it's maybe finding
ways to dig deep and see
maybe what we do have instead of thinking
of all of the challenges and
the hard things in front of us,
taking stock in some
of the positive things
that we do have and letting
that lift you up a little more.
I know it's not necessarily
going to change your situation,
but sometimes it's just a
different perspective mentally
can sometimes bring about
a little bit of change
or inspire change in a different way.
But it is tough.
I think leaning on people
that are close to you
and that you have a trust in.
And I think don't be afraid to reach out
because there are some incredibly
generous people out there
in their hearts where
they definitely want to
give whatever advice or tips to help out.
- Thank you.
(dog barking)
- We have another question from-
- There goes my little dog.
- Do we get to see your dog?
- Dog mom here, so he
must see someone outside.
- We are all dog fans here on our team.
Another question from
Dia Salmo on YouTube,
what inspired you to be a figure skater?
- Ah yes, so basically I
had seen an ice skating show
when I was younger, and I loved the music
and the performances and
the costumes, of course,
as a little girl.
And I think there was
so much about skating
that was magical.
And when I begged my mom to take me,
actually something that
ties in so perfect here
is she said, "Okay, well, when you're six
and you learn to read,
then I will take you to the ice rink."
So that was big motivation for me
to get reading and everything.
And from the first time I
tried it at six years old,
I just absolutely loved it
and kept asking to go back.
And I think the freedom on the ice
and the feeling of movement.
Kind of like skiing, you
feel the wind in your face
and your hair and there's just something
exhilarating about that.
And learning to do the jumps
and the different moves
on the ice was always a challenge,
but obviously incrementally
just great rewards
and that feeling of accomplishment
when I was able to learn something new.
So yeah, lots of things
inspired the skating.
- That's fascinating,
and I love that it was tied
to reading from the beginning.
Clearly your mom shared the
same values that you do.
- Yes, for sure.
- What were your favorite
books at that age?
- Ooh, okay, good question.
I'm trying to think.
Well, I had this one little
book called, "Bear's Birthday."
And it wasn't by a big publisher.
I think it was actually
like one of those books
given out at Hallmark or something.
But it had a little bear
that went on an adventure
on his birthday and you can
pull him out of each page
and stick him into the new environment
on the consecutive pages.
So it was always a lot of fun.
I'm trying to think of other little books
as a kid that age.
I mean, I remember,
maybe a little bit older,
loving "Charlotte's Web,"
and yes, you see a pig connection there.
I did have a big thing about pigs.
So of course, "Charlotte's
Web" was one of my favorites
as I was more middle school age.
- Yeah, well, you know, we've seen,
and Yu Wang from YouTube asks us,
"What do you think is the reason
that little kids like
to read the same book
over and over again?"
And related, "How can we get them
to explore different books?"
- You know, actually it's
a good thing to read books
over and over again.
The repetition is so good
for kids in that age range.
They'll hear the same words over and over
and starting to comprehend
things a little bit more.
So I definitely encourage
reading books over and over.
And we actually do that in
our Always Reading program.
And if that's what they wanna read,
or have read to them,
then at least they're
hearing something, right?
But I think if you find another book
with a similar character
or subject matter,
you can introduce that and say,
"Hey, this is just like
such-and-such book.
Let's see if there's a
new adventure in this
that you'd be interested in."
I think no matter what it is,
if you can get them interested in books,
that's the key.
But yeah, don't worry
about the repetition.
That's always a good thing.
- Absolutely, I'm there with you.
I remember the days when
our kids were young,
and for parents it seems
very, very repetitive.
I remember reading the
same books over and over,
night after night.
But in our work, we've
also noticed that children,
they'll read the same book,
but they'll be looking at the pictures
and if you ask them questions,
they may say something
different the next time.
And then sometimes we've
seen that children start,
even pre-reading, they will
start reciting the book,
because they'll remember it.
That's all good and part of learning.
- Yes, definitely.
- But like the tips on exploring
different books as well.
Sam Lewis from YouTube has a question.
"May I ask how to keep
a two-year-old still
long enough to read to?"
- Oh, (laughs) let's see,
it's been a long time
since my kids were two.
They're 16 and 18 now.
You know, let him sit on
your lap, or her, him or her,
and look at the book, feel the book.
Let them take charge.
I think sometimes let them turn the page.
Maybe say, "Hey, can you,"
for example, "Goodnight Moon,"
'cause that was one that
our kids wanted to hear
over and over and over,
and of course find the
little mouse on every page.
So maybe make it a little
bit of a game there, like,
"Oh, can you find the mouse on this page?"
And it kind of occupies them.
I know two years old is maybe a little,
eh, I think they would understand that.
But yeah, I think it's,
even five minutes is
enough to kinda start that.
And as they get older, they might,
you know, you could probably
build up to 10 minutes a day.
And even 10 minutes a day is
gonna make a huge difference
in creating a really strong foundation
for literacy habits and skills.
- And sometimes we can
borrow from teachers,
who are so good about setting
up those reading routines
in the school day.
Sometimes at home,
parents can set aside
some time for reading.
So after dinner or before bed,
children are growing
up expecting that time.
That sometimes helps, too,
when children get the routine.
- Yes, yes, they do.
- Sharon from Facebook asked us,
"Do you have a variety
of genres you prefer
for your personal reading?"
- Ooh, yeah, I kind of
bounce all over the map.
I mean, lately I've kind
of been going back to some,
more action and thriller.
I like a lot of spy novels
and kind of the
CIA-type suspense ones.
But then I read a couple of
great ones over the summer.
"Where the Crawdads Sing,"
I'm not sure if you guys
are familiar with that.
It was an incredible book.
So yeah, I kind of like to
explore all different things.
But I know I definitely love
adventure, and even fantasy.
Like "Lord of the
Rings," that whole series
was one of my favorite growing up.
- Great, so maybe now
going back to your past
as a kid of children in our demographic,
what was your training like
when you were first starting out
at six to eight years old?
- So you know, I mean, at six to eight,
I was still kind of getting
to know skating a little bit.
So it was maybe going a couple
times a week after school,
or whatever, and them maybe building up
to a few times a week.
So it wasn't real strenuous
training at that point.
Maybe a little bit older,
when I was closer to middle school age,
then I started going a
little bit before school.
So that's when the early mornings started
where my parents, or my
mom would get up early,
take me for an hour or two before school,
and then sometimes after school.
So I think that's more 11,
12 is when I started to get more serious
and committed to really
focusing in on more training.
- And then over the years as you competed,
how did you build up a mental
toughness that you needed
to prepare for the pressure
of being at the Olympics
and being on a worldwide stage?
- I mean, it comes gradually, right?
But I think my coach was really
incredible, Christy Ness,
at really preparing her students
to mentally be tough in competition.
And she was a great technician and trainer
that had us physically prepared,
but also wanted us to be
mentally tough as well.
So she was tough on us in training.
Like she never let up.
I wouldn't say too much
tough love, but a little bit.
She would try to get us into that feeling
and that atmosphere of a little
bit of nerves in practice
once in a while, especially
when we would perform,
practice our routines,
just so that when we felt
those nerves in competition,
it wasn't something that was new
and uncomfortable.
Well, it was uncomfortable,
but you knew how to deal with it
and you knew that, okay, even
though I feel a little shaky,
I can still go out there and perform okay.
- And what was it like
being one of the first
Asian American figure
skaters representing the US?
- I think I feel more of the impact now
than I did at the time.
You know, at the time, I didn't know that.
I knew that at the very,
very top world level,
there were very few Asian Americans.
At the time, Tiffany Chin,
who won a bronze world medal
and was US National
Champion in the early '80s
was one of my big idols and role models.
So I definitely looked at her
and I felt that connection
because she was also Asian American
and a California girl like me.
So I didn't really feel like,
oh, I'm trying to blaze a trail here,
like, oh, there's a lot of pressure.
I probably didn't really
realize what had happened
until after the Olympics
and when it was brought
more to my attention.
Like, oh hey, you're
the first Asian American
to win a gold in the Winter Olympics.
I was like, oh, really?
Okay, that's cool.
And I think when I saw
how much it meant to the
Asian American community,
I think that's when I
realized like, oh wow.
This does mean something.
And I think it made me reflect a lot more
and be even more appreciative
to the history of my family
here in the US and really the sacrifices
and the trail that they blazed
so that I could really
live that American dream.
- Wonderful, well, it's just
been such an inspiration
to have this conversation with you
and to hear about all your,
not only your Olympic history,
but also your deep work with
children in early literacy.
So thank you so much,
Kristi, for taking the time
and sharing with our audience.
- Absolutely.
Thank you, Caroline, it
was so great to talk to you
and an honor to talk to you, too,
and just a huge fan of Khan Academy Kids
and just love what you
guys do, too, to encourage
all of that early education
because it's so important.
- Well, thank you so much.
And if folks want to see this,
just find this podcast
wherever you get your podcasts
and look for Khan Academy Ed Talks
and we will see you next time.
Thank you!